from the botched afghanistan exit to a
massive surge in covid americans have
had enough of his incompetence according
to a new poll only 42 percent approve of
biden's performance while 50 percent
disapprove and just 34 percent approve
of the president's handling of foreign
policy
all right so dana i'll start with you
okay we never got to you in the last
season all right you know he promised
that he was going to make everything
right that trump botched the he botched
the covet response and he was going to
make everything right now coverts a
disaster and the numbers show it
so i think that's
picking up on something i was thinking
about earlier today so when he ran he
basically said i'm going to be a
transitional person like transitional
candidate
i think kind of signaling he wouldn't
necessarily run for a second term he
said i'll you won't have to worry about
me i'll just be the caretaker everything
will be really smooth no one will ever
have to think about it
he didn't run on fundamentally changing
the economic system of the united states
he didn't run on basically beating a
hasty retreat out of afghanistan and
leaving americans behind and green card
holders and then the people that helped
us uh have no help either
in the polls that you saw in quinnipiac
poll in particular the uh independents
are down to i think 32 percent approval
and women was then i think more like 47
46 if i'm looking at jessica she looks
at these polls a little bit more closely
than i do but women are really like the
bread and butter for the democratic
party so if all those numbers are going
down then you have to look at the
durability of the negativity so these
numbers have been going down for a while
polls take a little bit of time to catch
up the afghanistan issue has been going
on for about 30 days now you're starting
to see that manifest and even though so
many in the media are helping
it doesn't seem to be improving his
numbers at all they are pretty bad i
also think that they're really out of
touch
they seem detached they um haven't he
hasn't gotten out too much he went to
california to campaign for gavin newsom
stopped in idaho to make it an official
trip to talk about wildfires other than
that i think that they seem pretty
disconnected because people don't want
this 3.5 trillion dollars necessarily
but their main concern right now for
workers out there uh is inflation
because the increased cost of all their
goods and services like even like or
like meat for example and gasoline and
milk everything that's eating up their
wages and you know jesse the economy
biden stands at 42 approval while 52
disapprove of how he's handling the
economy so he'll try to tax and spend
his way out of it that's what democrats
do and whenever democrats do that they
lose big in the midterms and if that
happens and you have him with sub 45
approval and 60 percent of the country
thinks we're going in the wrong
direction that's going to be pretty
deadly kovid's the x factor because he
said we killed it this summer then it
came back and we're at nearly 2 000
daily deaths on average
so the problem from hit is tricky
because the democrats who are largely
vaxxed
don't act like everything's good they're
scared of everything they're scared of
the unvaxxed democrats are scared of the
vaxxed they're scared of traveling so
his group of people that supports him
they're not acting like things are going
back to normal and he needs people to
believe that things are going back to
normal that's why he was elected okay
are the democrats scared
i'm personally frightened at this moment
just because you're sitting next to me i
didn't say it you said it but now that
it's out there um yeah democrats are
scared and there's so much conflicting
information about how you're going to
get a breakthrough infection why people
are getting hospitalized masking works
it doesn't work etc um but the core
thing at least that i'm focused on is
for the midterms will the economy become
untethered from the coveted question
because biden was able to win in 2020
because the economy was linked to what's
going on with covid everyone knew that
the country was shut down because we
have this health emergency so if by the
midterms we're largely back to normal
which is my expectation then will there
be a punishment against democrats for
what's going on if inflation continues
to grow etc versus people saying yes i
may like how we're handling the vaccine
mandate and the masking or whatever and
to dana's point about women
i think it's a really valuable one
because democrats have a shifting
coalition right now it used to be pretty
straight up that it was minority voters
that were driving
our positive results but then when you
look at 2020 but a lot of white suburban
women specifically that's how we won
states like georgia and arizona and as
if that begins just
sorry parenthetical
uh
it says scare quotes not not parentheses
um
then that obviously affects what's going
to happen all right so very quickly very
quickly very very very quickly first
time now surgeries so you're not asking
my question okay surgeries are being
cancelled in hospitals in washington
she's going to take up all the time
okay and severe shortages of beds and
lack of beds in tennessee and kentucky
and alabama i mean that's real isn't it
yeah it is real i mean he was elected to
be a caretaker turns out he's our
undertaker oh america is dying under joe
biden's watch uh i believe he's playing
a game of crisis croquet is that he said
croquet that little game so he's trying
to knock inflation he's trying to knock
afghanistan he's trying to knock crime
these are all the top balls that could
get that could destroy the democrats
he's trying to knock that off by filling
it up with covet stuff i don't think the
covet stuff would affect him as much as
crime homelessness education afghanistan
and especially your point inflation
because that's where it hurts everybody
across the board especially uh the
blue-collar worker so i think that right
now
they're benefiting from anything from
covid because they've got so many other
problems i also want to make a
comparison to trump's numbers uh you
could say that in in the in polling that
trump's numbers were similar at this
point but it's a false comparison
because trump numbers were uh were
actually amazingly good given the
relentless vomit of fake news and
smoking gun stories and general
emotional hysteria by this numbers
aren't about his personality they're
about his incompetence and he was
supposed to be the competent we knew
what trump was we knew what the package
was we saw him in the apprentice but we
were promised a caretaker we got like dr
death yeah no we got someone that we
have to take care of i went on brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now